[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue dans dimanche
en politique votre émission de débat en
franche comté nous sommes ce matin au
parc des glacis de besançon juste devant
la gare viotte et nous allons nous
intéresser pendant une demi heure en
direct à l'avenir des petites lignes
ferroviaires car au delà du statut de la
sncf au delà du statut des cheminots
c'est sûrement l'autre bataille du rail
à venir ligne des hirondelles ligne des
horlogers liaison haut saônoise faut-il
maintenir coûte que coûte ses dessertes
parfois très peu fréquenté faut-il miser
sur le bus qu'on nous présente
paradoxalement comme moins polluant que
le train faut-il encore parier sur la
concurrence et la privatisation on veut
en débattre avec nos trois invités que
je vous présente tout de suite d'abord
michel neugnot vous êtes le premier vice
président de la région bourgogne franche
comté en charge des transports
c'est donc vous qui gérait ce dossier
des ter que l'état veut transférer
intégralement aux régions également sur
ce plateau en plein air patrick noble et
vous êtes le vice président régional de
la fnh note la fédération nationale des
associations d'usagers des transports
vous représentez en quelques heures ce
qui prennent le train et puis un
cheminot sur ce plateau jean christophe
gossard vous êtes le secrétaire régional
cgt cheminots dojo orgone franche-comté
bonjour à tous les trois merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation
alors vous le savez en cette émission
c'est aussi la vôtre vous en avez
l'habitude vous pouvez l'a commentée sur
les réseaux sociaux avec le mode yes qui
s'affiche dit mme paul fc comme dimanche
en politique franche comté et puis vous
pouvez aussi interpeller nos invités
leur poser vos questions sur notre page
internet sur le site de france 3
bourgogne franche comté je me ferai
d'ailleurs le relais de vos questions
tout au long de ce débat alors michel
neugnot dans la foulée du rapport
spinetta publié mi février le
gouvernement a donc présenté son projet
de réforme de la sncf
edouard philippe a annoncé vouloir
transférer entièrement aux régions la
gestion des petites lignes ces lignes
présentées comme coûtant trop cher pour
le peu de voyageurs qu'elle transporte
n'est ce pas là un cadeau empoisonné est
ce que finalement l'état ne se décharge
il pas des mauvaises nouvelles
c'est à dire que ces lignes la elle
coûte
recherche pour peu de voyageurs qu'elle
transporte déjà je ne permettrai de vous
dire que je n'aime pas beaucoup ce terme
de petites lignes
je préfère parler de réseaux capillaires
parce que l'importance de ning c'est par
rapport au nombre d'usagers de voyageurs
à prendre en charge et nous pas dans
l'absolu
deuxièmement le rapport spinetta en ce
qui concerne la partie réseau n'est plus
à l'ordre du jour régions de france
s'est battue pour qu'effectivement le
rapport spinetta ne soit pas la base de
la loi du gouvernement notamment sur les
infrastructures dans la l'homme qui va
être mis en place
troisième élément troisième élément ce
qui compte pour parler des
infrastructures c'est le rapport du
conseil d'orientation des
infrastructures qui est le rapport
présidé par philippe duron
dans ce rapport nous souhaitons car si
en fait le rapport durieux girard cheese
les priorités en termes d'impact avant
et que cela mon va rester à l'essentiel
dans ce rapport du rond il ya trois
scénarios
nous nous voulons que ce soit au moins
le scénario 2 est troisième élément sur
ses lignes avant de rentrer dans le
détail bourgogne franche comté
nous souhaitons nous voulons que le
contrat de plan de contrats de plan en
cours qui actuellement derrière l'accord
je précisais le contrat de plan c un
accord entre l'état et la région les sur
les finances hur le magicien le nord des
îles ferroviaire des infrastructures
ferroviaires
ce contrat de plan qui actuellement
n'est pas assurée dans son financement
il manque d'action allemand 10 milliards
pour le faire nous souhaitons que
l'octroi de plans soient fait
intégralement et que son financement
soit assuré
voilà donc les bases donc plus rapport
spinetta je vous propose de ne pas en
parler parce qu'il n'est plus à leur
donner ce que nous avons demandé des
régions ce que transfert aux régions de
la gestion de ses dessertes ferroviaires
est ce que c'est un cadeau empoisonné
est ce qu'il n'ya pas là un implant une
impossibilité comptable de maintenir ces
lignes non pour les régions pas d'accord
cela demande des régions compte tenu des
circonstances totalement différente
d'une région à l'eau vous avez des
régions comme
nouvelle aquitaine où ils ont
essentiellement un réseau en ligne 7 à 9
des capillaires et cela représente pour
tout rénover un milliard deux cents
millions nous bourgogne franche comté la
part de ces réseaux capitulaire par
rapport à l'ensemble note de trésor n'a
pas la même dimension
donc ce qui a été demandé c'est de
pouvoir travailler dans le temps avec le
gouvernement pourrait avec sncf réseau
pour traiter la sphère région par région
et nous allons rentrer dans le détail si
vous voulez pour dire comment ça va se
passer et comment ce sera possible
comptablement de tenir et de maintenir
l'activité sur toutes les lignes que
nous avons dois vous dire que pour
crédibiliser notre parole nous sommes
une des seules régions avoir créé une
nouvelle ligne avec la ligne au niveau
de belfort vers elle que nous mettons en
place
patrick noble et le premier ministre
edouard philippe disait que les français
qu'ils prennent le train ou non fait de
plus en plus cher pour un service public
qui marche de moins en moins bien
y at il selon vous un problème de coût
par rapport aux services est ce que vous
êtes d'accord avec le premier ministre
ou c'est le transport ferroviaire c'est
un système intégré c'est très compliqué
à gérer
et effectivement il faut il faut de
l'argent pour faire fonctionner donc
on a en plus dans un système où le le
coup le coût pour l'usager est très
différent en fonction du train qui
pensent y prend le tgv ou un ter
c'est tout à fait différente en matière
de tarification
donc est ce quelqu'un le tract
recherches je pense pas le train ne
coûte pas trop cher il faut il faut bien
se rendre compte que l'infrastructure
ferroviaire
elle n'est assurée que par par l'argent
public
contrairement aux hommes les routiers
nomique viable justement sans doute oui
oui la seule activité ferroviaire
rentable pour la sncf ce sont quelques
lignes tgv faut bien le dire tout le
reste il s'est financé par l'argent
public donc on va continuer comme ça il
faut pas il faut pas rêver donc ils font
connaître toujours un peu plus d'argent
dans le train ce que je voudrais dire
simplement en dehors muscat que vous
avez sous titrer votre émission la
bataille du rail archers pas si c'est
une bataille mais en tout cas ce qui
joue en ce moment c'est l'avenir de
l'entreprise historique et l'avenir du
ferroviaire du chemin de fer c'est très
important et ça peut pas se faire en
quelques semaines il faut il faut le
dire donc les les usagers ce qu'ils
demandent c'est d'une part une
négociation sérieuse et bonne
concertation comme ça se fait maintenant
ensuite on sera très vigilants sur la
qualité de l'information si on doit
aller au conflit et on exigera un plan
de transport qu'ils soient affichés 24
euros de manière à ce que les usagers
puissent prendre leurs dispositions
jean-christophe gossard la théorie on va
dire du gouvernement en ce moment c'est
que c'est finalement le statut de
cheminot qui plombe en quelque sorte la
cour la compétitivité de la sncf que
propose votre syndicat pour
sauvegarder l'intégralité du réseau et
notamment ses petits thing alors vous
n'aimez pas tous ce terme là mais c'est
le terme qui a été employée par le
gouvernement et par le fameux rapport
spinetta alors d'abord le statut n'est
pas responsable des dysfonctionnements
et de la dette
ça c'est une chose ensuite moi je
voudrais revenir sur les propos de
monsieur neugnot sur le rapport spinetta
n'en parle plus bas non on en parle
pourquoi parce que déjà dans les
premières pages du projet de loi il est
cité comme la référence
donc lorsque ça fait un tollé sur les
9000 kilomètres de lignes il est cité
monsieur dans le projet de loi je lis
ici je vous donnerai le verbatim comme
vous aimez le dire le projet de loi
donc le rapport spinetta est cité de
manière importante dans les deux
premières pages dans le rapport spinetta
effectivement il ya 9000 km de lignes
qui était pointé du doigt le premier
ministre quand il a vu un peu le tollé
que ça faisait notamment dans la
ruralité en région a dit non non non ce
ne sera pas la réforme des petites
lignes nous on appelle ça la cgt j'irai
des lignes régionales de proximité
puisque les petites lignes c'est vrai
que ce un terme un peu et donc giresse
et jean région et donc est donc
effectivement on décide pas des
fermetures à paris ce qui sous-entend
que en gros le gouvernement va donner le
sale boulot de sous-traitance aux
régions l'engagement qui est pris sur le
financement
c'est un milliard et demi c'est c'est
d'ailleurs repris dans le dossier de
presse sur sur notre région
monsieur ne nous a parlé de belfort
delle tous les angles les engagements
qui sont pris ces jusqu'en 2020 le cpe
air 2015 2020 après on n'a aucune aucune
visibilité
monsieur 2
on parle ici je le disais en ouverture
des missions de la ligne des hirondelles
qui traverse le jura de part en part de
la ligne d horloger qui relie besançon
au doux jusqu'à la suisse on parle aussi
des liaisons en haute saône
que compte faire la région de ces lignes
est ce que vous leur réserver le même
avenir par exemple que oyonnax saint
claude qui est où il ya plus de train
depuis quelques semaines maintenant
parce que ça coûtait trop cher
oyonnax ses actes ce n'est pas parce que
ça coûte l'être cher
on y verra ses pas sur notre région mais
je vais déjà dire quelque chose
ce débat permet déjà d'expliquer comment
ça fonctionne bien que vous répondiez
hammam je retournerai pas votre question
c'est à dire vous avez cité la ligne des
hirondelles
est-ce que les bourguignons franc
comtois savent quelle est la proportion
payés par l'état dans le cadre du
contractant de cet hymne des hirondelles
très peu l'état ne paye que 5%
le reste est payé par ssf réseau et la
région
cet ennemi % et 87 et demi donc la cage
c'est bien celle de vous poser trop
choquer je vous dis sur laquelle vous
avez clairement que vous avez les moyens
dans la ligne des hirondelles la ligne d
et rondelles nous avons prévu de
travailler nous avons prévu de la souris
mais mais le problème on rentre d'un
toute la problématique de sncf réseau
c'est que le calcul des coûts les
charges en faisant passer par la grotte
métallique est simple raison que
nécessaire pour les grands chantiers sur
ses lignes là à mettre des coûts
exorbitants
nous avons fait des calculs et d'autres
régions ont fait si nous faisons comme
dans le fret ir la possibilité que les
régions commande directement comment
directement aux entreprises qui
réalisent et travaux vous pouvez
diminuer le coût de 30 à 40 % et en
diminuant le coût de 30 à 40%
bars de la région aussi faire que cela
puisse paraître vinça trouvée diminue et
donc que l'on saisit à un autre modèle
économique a brûlé et quand nous disons
que les régions sont favorables à cet
autre modèle économique et sont prêts à
prendre parti sur la ligne d horloger la
ligne d horloge il ya 12 millions de
travaux qui sont faits actuellement nous
allons ramener 20 millions de plus dans
le cadre du contractant pour accélérer
nous avons tenu la possibilité par les
suisses de continuer avec notre matériel
de desservir la suisse jusqu'en 2030
parce qu'il ya un risque
d'incompatibilité maintenant c'est réglé
servent ils nous avaient passé un accord
international avec les suisses pour ce
faire savez vous que les chiffes
interdisent l'utilisation du diesel à
partir de 2022
c'est un sujet que j'aborderai
certainement tout à l'heure donc les
lignes que vous avez cités nous allons
continuer d'investir dedans
nous allons les maintenir et pour vous
dire dans la nouvelle la ligne d
horloger nous avons mis au mois de
décembre une desserte entre valdahon et
besançon supplémentaires au mois de
décembre prochain
nous allons remettre une desserte
supplémentaire en direction de la suisse
donc nous montrons à travers cela que
nous croyons en train que nous voulons
le développer
mais le modèle est à bout de souffle il
faut le rénover faut faire preuve d'un
peu de capacité à modifier les choses et
c'est à ce prix que nous défendrons le
modèle ferroviaire et que nous sauverons
patrick noble et les promesses les
les déclarations d'intention du
vice-président de la région s'avoue
satisfait écoutez on était satisfait
dans le cadre du contrat de plan
etat-région de 6 millions qui ont été
engagés sur les lignes des hirondelles
mais il en faudrait quatre ou cinq fois
plus pour la pérenniser mélangez
réellement oui donc une roue donc on est
tout à fait favorable au maintien de ces
lignes évidemment on croit nous à
l'effet réseau et au maillage globale du
réseau c'est-à-dire les périphériques où
les lignes capillaire qui rabattent sur
les dix principales des usagers ou du
fret
ce que je sais ce que je voudrais dire à
monsieur moniot quand même quand il
parle de la ligne des hirondelles
il ya déjà une partie qui a été amputée
entre oyonnax et saint claude
certes c'est une décision du conseil
régional auvergne rhône-alpes mais pas
opposé au contraire et je dis qu'il a
enclenchée justement il ya des bus
maintenant sur cette année le rapport à
nous les six mois terminés en plus vous
parler de mes deux modèles économiques
votre modèle économique pour la ligne
des hirondelles c'est le tourisme
on n'a pas attendu la nouvelle région
pour atouts pour développer le tourisme
save et les offices de tourisme ne donne
j'ai parlé de nouvelles modes nouveaux
modèles économiques pour réaliser des
travaux
je n'ai pas parlé d'exploitation nous
sommes en train de parler actuellement
des travaux à réaliser
il faut un autre modèle économique pour
réaliser les travaux le reste on pourra
parler d'une valeur de notre offre de
service en dehors du tourisme il a été
mon sens il faut ramener les nouvelles
il faut que les livres soient bon état
vous ne pouvez pas mener
il ya un ordre des choses c'est le
préambule évidemment évidemment il ya
christophe qui nous a envoyé une
question et qui vous dit puisqu'on en
parle beaucoup et c'est le cas sur
oyonnax 5 l'ofc et des bus à la place
des trains dorénavant et christophe
naudi si un jour le train vient à
disparaître pour le bus alors je
prendrai ma voiture
le but ce n'est pas confortable il est
fatigant ne peut pas travailler à
l'intérieur
jean-christophe gossard comment vous
réagissez
à cette perspective de remplacer par
endroit les trains par des bus est ce
que finalement le bus c'est pas une
solution à moindre coût et plus
écologique on nous l'a présenté aussi
comme plus écologique sur des lignes où
il ya très peu de voyage alors alors
pour la cgt le bus doit être une
complémentarité du rail
ça doit être et non pas une une mise en
parallèle de la ligne ferroviaire un ce
que d'ailleurs fait ce que d'ailleurs
font les fonds l'écart macron pourra
dire l'écart présidentielle là la chose
qui est important aussi c'est ce que dit
monsieur nos blessures
la cohérence nationale de maillage du
réseau aujourd'hui monsieur neugnot peut
dire belfort-delle 10 millions et c'est
très bien on est d'accord avec tous ces
avions 200 millions 10 millions au
comptant de plan état région de financer
a jusque jusqu'en 2020
c'est très bien mais quel pérennité
derrière 2020 et on parle du routier
parle du routier parce qu'on nous avait
dit nous avait dit dans vos questions le
tract ils trop cher mais leur uci
regardons un peu aussi le rocher ne pose
pas les modes entre eux on est pour une
complémentarité que ce soit ferroviaires
fluviales aérien et routier y compris
dans le fret marchandises mais il ya 16
milliards d'euros par an n'avaient de
d'entretien du réseau routier et des
investissements la pollution la
pollution coût de 100 milliards par an
dont 75 % qui sont dues au transport
donc quand je les accidents dans les
galeries d'art et les logiques des
petits détails seraient mauvais il faut
il faut comparer ce qui est comparable
il faut qu'on part il faut regarder il
faut comparer vous comprendre 7
milliards d'euros qui sont dus
malheureusement aux accidents de la
route
avec 3600 blessés 600 décès en 2016 et +
là les bouchons qui coûte 20 milliards
d'euros effectivement effectivement
c'est facile de dire le rail coûte cher
mais il répond si un aménagement du
territoire
l'industrialisation il répond aussi à un
ne demande écologique environnementale
et la question du fret ferroviaire qui
est souvent pas traiter ou maltraitées
par parler par les médias et aussi
central il n'y a rien dans cette réforme
sur le fret ferroviaire et le fret
ferroviaire la relance du fret
ferroviaire permettrait aussi sur ses
lignes régionales de proximité sur sur
l'ensemble des lignes aussi de diminuer
le coût d'entretien enfin alors rapport
au tonnage le fret a été ouvert à la
concurrence et plusieurs années
maintenant ce sera aussi le cas pour les
transports de voyageurs flavien touré
j'aimerais qu'on avance et qu on parle
de cette ouverture à la concurrence
vous êtes montrés très volontariste sur
cette question il ya déjà plus d'un an
vous militiez pour que la bourgogne
franche comté ouvre notamment ses
petites lignes à la concurrence pourquoi
le privé réussirait-il à faire mieux et
moins cher que là c'est déjà fait pas le
privé à la concurrence lui où ce sont
des filiales ou ce sont des filiales
transdev capitaux casey délais des
robots fait pas tellement privée quand
c'est arrivé à une filiale de la
deutsche bahn s'est pas tellement privé
les ans les représentants via lui vous
militez pour et déjà anticipé cette
dernière la conquête sera le quatrième
pays paquet ferroviaire oblige à le
faire pourquoi pourquoi ne pas voir
monsieur bouchard au de la règle si ça
peut avoir des exceptions
voilà les utiliseront il peut y avoir
des exceptions mais les conditions
d'exception ne sont pas en réalité pour
les réseaux ter ce que nous disons
l'ouvertue la concurrence c'est un autre
métier
ce n'est pas passé une convention à
kayes etc
il faut monter en puissance en capacité
pour le réaliser est ce que nous disons
à la lumière de ce qui s'est passé sur
le fret ferroviaire on est passé de tout
à rien de rien à tout selon le point de
vue dont on se passe on se place il y a
nécessité à apprendre à faire cela et à
donner aux régions la capacité d'une
montée en puissance progressive
c'est la raison principale puis senio
qui très concrètement quelle ligne et
quand puisque ça et bien en chambre du
sol impossible et nous sommes en train
de finaliser la convention
il y aura pour l'ouverture à la
concurrence il faut attendre la loi pour
que l'on puisse voir sa réellement nous
donnerons 2 origine destination
principale sur la région bourgogne
franche comté et nous choisirons le
moment venu ce qui détériore - la
cohérence du réseau pas celle où je suis
d'accord et que sa ligne caen mais non
parce que c'est pas encore arrêtée les
élus de la majorité ne le savent pas
encore bien nous avions parié les lignes
nous étions dans les musées autant le
chrono jeune jane désire engager de
belfort delle nous étions partis sur
d'un cahier des charges un ensemble de
lignes ou l'origine destination
principale c'était nevers dijon
il y avait effectivement les lignes du
morvan il y avait effectivement là
l'idée giraudel il y avait effectivement
belfort-delle voilà mais ça c'était pour
engager des discussions avec la sncf et
cote dans la convention réel nous
déterminons lesquels désorganise le
moins désorganise moelle le réseau tel
qu'il est actuellement
patrick n'oublie ce que les usagers ont
à y gagner écoutez si si c'est pour le
maintien de la ligne
oui si c'est la condition effectivement
ils ont tout à gagner
le problème de position au niveau
national avoue tête pour l'ouverture de
la concurrence
on est pour l'ouverture la concurrence
régulée régulé au nous soit sous forme
de la même saison dans l'ue que la
flottille niveau national si je les
verrai pour ces jeunes y aussi ce qui
existe sur les réseaux urbains et ça
fonctionne bien je pense pas qu'on
puisse se targuer de dysfonctionnements
le problème je tiens à revenir très
rapidement sur sur les sur le quart
parce que vous donnons est très rapide
mais je veux bien qu'on avance correcte
de la concurrence mois sur la toute
l'egypte dont on parle les horlogers et
les hirondelles
il ya déjà la mixité est à dire qu il ya
à la fois d'être certain ferroviaire et
des soeurs par car et la tentation est
grande de l'opérateur et de l'autorité
on dépense pas du jeu vous permet pas de
dire ça écoutez vous permet pas de dire
les faits en tout cas 9 contre nommé
monsieur noble et c'est la région qui
sait ce qu'elle va faire et pas vous
donc je vous permet pas de dire que
notre position est de remettre la ligne
des hirondelles ou la liste des
horlogers sur le cas je disais tentation
aime sa une ce n'est pas notre attention
donc ne répondait pas m'appeler quand on
en prend on en prend un coup sur la
concurrence on ressortira les bandes si
jamais votre la composition change ça se
fait il faut il faut surtout jauger le
potentiel de ces lignes vous dites
qu'ils y sont présentés peu fréquentée
c'est vrai mais ce qu'elles peuvent
intéresser bien des survivants de la
sncf alors ça c'est le problème de la
région ne suis pas certain que les
opérateurs privés se précipite sur cette
finale il ya un potentiel énorme
ne serait ce que pour les frontaliers
entre morteau et la ligne d horloger
entre pontarlier et valoir également
pour l'instant il ya un aller retour
pour les frontaliers
il en faudrait plusieurs le problème du
ferroviaire c'est que c'est le premier
train qui coûte cher après c'est un
système bas coûts croissants
plus vous mettez de tra et puis vous
rentabilisez le système donc on est loin
de cette logique il s'est pas exprimé
sur la question
l'ouverture à la concurrence sur
l'ouverture à la concurrence d'abord
c'est ce n'est pas une obligation
cela c'est une décision s'il vous plaît
c'est une décision politique du
gouvernement en fonction et donc
effectivement il peut y avoir des
dérogations c'est son choix ce sera le
cas pour l'ile-de-france qui est pas
alors alors envoyé alors alors until à
dire que l on nous dit d'un côté que
l'ouverture à la concurrence elle doit
être plus avoir lieu fin 2010 neuf en
régions
et puis à paris c'est 2034 2039
le gros problème de l'ouverture à la
concurrence c'est que c'est la fin de la
péréquation c'est à dire aujourd'hui on
s il vous plait juninho je vous ai pas
coupé à liz avait l'habitude je sais
mais ne coupez pas l'ouverture la fin de
la péréquation c'est à dire que en gros
les lignes qui marche le mieux
on pourrait dire financent celles qui
marchent moins bien je dis pas qu'elles
sont déficitaires parce que c'est un
investissement pour l'aménagement du
territoire et c'est ce système qui fait
que le système marche si demain on ouvre
à la concurrence
on va seriez ligne par ligne train par
train effectivement on va aller sur un
modèle où on sera sur les seuls
seules les grandes lignes rentables et
puis regardons ce que ça fait
l'ouverture à la concurrence au fret 30%
de moins toute entreprise privée toutes
entreprises confondues
l'opérateur historique et les
entreprises privées deux mains je suis
désolé une entreprise privée comme colas
rail ou autre peut très bien prendre le
marché du de l'ouverture à la
concurrence et en angleterre
en angleterre les prix ont augmenté de
117 % en vingt ans ça il faut quand même
le dire aux usagers
je pense qu'on rentre dans la discussion
du café du commerce et il faut être un
peu plus sera sur le sujet pourquoi je
le savais je veux je vous explique
mais mélanger mélanger on est d'un
système très complexe
mélanger ce qui s'est passé en
angleterre mélanger le fret avec la
problématique que nous avons retour ce
sont des problèmes totalement différent
le fret dans toute l'europe est en crise
le ferait de temps toute l'europe façon
sur le très long et sur l'augmentation
assez jury du prix des billets en
angleterre c'est réel mais en angleterre
l'état financent 70% l'infrastructure
en france l'état finance 30% de
l'infrastructure dont vous voyez on peut
composer les chiffres durée modèle ce
que ce que je la médecine sur la partie
ce qu'il faut pas oublier c'est que ce
sont les régions qui depuis 2002 sont en
responsabilité ce n'est pas la sncf pour
les ter qui choisit ce que l'on doit
faire
ce sont les régions qui commande et en
région bourgogne franche comté j'aurais
quand même le dire la nouvelle
convention nous allons mettre 7 % de
trains en plus en circulation
nous allons mettre 5 % en plus de trains
kilomètres
donc nous sommes pas dans une politique
malthusienne nous sommes dans une
politique du développement et les
réformes que nous avons fait sur quatre
derniers mois de l'amener amène pour les
occasionnels 21% le plus de
fréquentation en bourgogne franche comté
et 40 % de plus pour les jeunes dont on
a travaillé à casser le modèle tel qu'il
était pour faire en sorte vous faire
réagir à une remarque de christine eu
une remarque de christine qui nous
disent ces lignes elle parle des petites
lignes allant vous n'avez pas le terme
encore une fois mais ces lignes sont
essentiels pour permettre à de nombreux
salariés de zones isolées d'aller
travailler dans les centres urbains cela
limite n'a dit la désertification des
zones de moyenne montagne avec ce réseau
aussi il ya une notion d'aménagement du
territoire d'égalité du territoire vous
êtes tous d'accord là dessus monsieur de
l'état fait on parle pas de cet aspect
là mais la transition écologique
l'aménagement du territoire l'effet
réseau tout ça c'est du concret
le transport dont les poèmes transport
pour les captifs y avait tout le monde
n'a pas une voiture effectivement est ce
que vous imaginez que cinq lots d'un
journée et nenê n'est plus de ne sont
plus desservis par la voie ferrée
ils sont en train de se battent déjà
pour garder leur hôpital et leur service
public c'est vraiment catastrophique la
lure a failli connaître le même sort
donc il est absolument nécessaire de
maintenir le maillage ferroviaire très
rapidement très rapidement le problème
on n'en a pas parlé
c'est le problème du financement du
ferroviaire globalement la cgt a des
propositions notamment sur la
renationalisation des autoroutes et je
vous remet d'ailleurs le 2e rapport
alternatif de la gt avec les
propositions de financement après
service public ferroviaire
merci à tous les trois merci à tous les
trois dans un instant le flash
d'information en région à la semaine
prochaine pour un nouveau débat